welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can watch just
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go along
with this video check out the link in
the description below alright so today
is bonus day number three and we're
gonna learn how to optimize our diet as
I said 70 percent of the time people
live in stress and living in stress is
living in survival now all organisms in
nature can tolerate short-term stress
you know a deer gets chased by a pack of
coyotes when it out runs the Coyotes it
goes back to grazing and the event is
over and the definition of stress is
when your brain and body are knocked out
of balance out of homeostasis the stress
response is what the body and Nate Lee
does to return itself back to order so
you're driving down the road someone
cuts you off you jam on the brakes you
may give them the finger and then you
settle back down then the event is over
and boom now everything's back back to
normal but what if it's not a predator
that's waiting for you outside the cave
but what if it's your coworker sitting
right next to you and all day long
you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons when you turn on a
stress response and you can't turn it
off now you're headed for a disease
because no organism in nature can live
an emergency mode for that extended
period of time
it's a scientific fact that the hormones
of stress down regulate genes and create
disease long term affects human beings
because of the size of the neocortex we
can turn on the stress response just by
thought alone we can think about our
problems and turn on those chemicals
that means then our thoughts could make
us sick so if it's possible that our
thoughts could make us sick is it
possible that our thoughts can make us
well the answer is absolutely yes so
then what are the emotions that are
connected to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility hatred
competition fear anxiety worry pain
suffering guilt shame
unworthiness their envy jealousy those
are all created by the hormones of
stressin and psychology calls them
normal human states of consciousness I
call those altered states of
consciousness so then we tend to
remember those traumatic events more
because in survival you better be ready
if it happens again that's an and in the
ones survival gene is switched on you
could have ten really great things that
happen to you in your day and you just
have one bad thing that happens and you
cannot take your attention off that bad
that that unhappy thing because the
survival gene is switched on it's really
interesting how does epigenetics come
into play and all this like what's
actually happening you've talked pretty
profoundly about proteins and like
really at a deep level how we're
signalling to our genetics to create
these kinds of changes what does that
actually look like
well epigenetics epi means above the
gene and many years ago after the DNA
helix was discovered by Watson and Crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
turns out less than 5% more like 1% of
people on the planet are born with a
genetic condition like type 1 diabetes
or tay-sachs disease or sickle cell
anemia the other 95 to 99 percent are
created by lifestyle and by choices you
can take two identical twins exact same
genome one dies at 51 the other one dies
at 85 same gene different environment so
all of a sudden they said we lied that
was wrong it's not genes that create
disease it's the environment that
signals the gene that creates disease
well ok but that's not the whole truth
too because you could have two people
working side by side in the same factory
one gets cancer after being exposed to a
carcinogenic for 25 years both working
for 25 years the other one has no cancer
at all so there must be some internal
order that would cause one person to not
get it while another one does so is it
possible then if the environment signals
the gene and it does and the end product
of an experience in the environment is
call
motion can you signal the gene ahead of
the environment by embracing an elevated
emotion we've done the research on this
where we've measured 7,500 different
gene expressions in a group of people I
came to an advanced event for four days
and we had them doing a seated
meditation a walking meditation a laying
down meditation a standing meditation
and at the end of four days just four
days the common eight genes that were
upregulated two genes to suppress cancer
cells and tumor growth two genes for
neurogenesis the growth of new neurons
in response to novel experiences and
learning the gene that signals stem
cells to go to damaged areas and repair
them the gene for oxidative stress was
upregulated we started seeing all these
genes that are very very healthy to
cause the body to flourish imagine if
people were doing that for three months
we also measured telomeres the little
shoestrings on the end of DNA that tell
us our biological age we asked people to
do the work meditation five out of seven
days for 60 days measure their telomeres
that determine their biological age
sixty days later seventy four percent of
the people lengthen their telomeres 40%
significant change 20% a very remarkable
change that means that they got a little
bit of their life back if they're
lengthened by 10%
they got 10% of their life back we all
talk about business all the time but the
aspect of health is the most important
part nobody talks about it yeah nobody
talks about it most business men and
women go around and you're traveling all
the time you know the best things then
you're you're a two and three dinners a
night you're drinking because you born
with a lot of people you're drinking
you're happy because you're off you know
you're not sleeping you're in between
climates and things of that nature and
then all of a sudden it implodes and you
have nothing left
yeah crazy yeah do you have a schedule
every day then for your health right now
mmm I try and you know I'm not perfect I
go back to the book often to look at all
the things that I want to do so you know
I'll give you example sway you know
loves to say hey I
I get up and I bust down you know four
sets of 25 push-ups a day and gets my
adrenaline running I was doing that
until I blew my shoulder out there and
something else right yeah so now what I
do I sure do i I was actually diving in
Mexico and trying to embarrass my
daughter's what this was this dive and I
hurt my shoulder I fires myself but but
but you know all right so now I have to
adjust that so what do I do
maybe now after I will answer emails
after uh when I do but I'll be walking
on the treadmill for two hour answering
them you know later on so i get i get by
put the steps and i'll do leg lifts I'll
do whatever the case is but again it's
always adjusting right I'm not gonna
make any suit oh my heart blown out and
I can't do anything right there's a cow
Manor climb Mount Kilimanjaro you know I
was so late oh what the hell's wrong
with me I got some on my shoulder here
and I can't work out a single thing that
helped me the most to click was not
eating past 7:30 now depending on what
time you go to bed I'm you're looking at
that I mean not eating a grape not a
grape not a rice or a crispy past 7:30
and the thing about it is I'd started it
at 7 o'clock and then just I was killing
myself trying to get home Oh 7
I remember we'd be talk and she's not
gonna go but it's singular for a lot of
people who making bad food choices if
you just do that that will turn there's
a lipstick in that yeah it's real it's
magical if this just it's just like just
like you brush your teeth you say 7:30 I
do not eat past 7:30 and it the farther
up you can move that the better you get
now this is the key this is what really
saved me I remember you told me this day
we're walking around I went why the hell
you wait 10 years ago yeah okay Bob said
to me when you cut off your eating you
cut off your eating at least two to
three hours before you go to bed he goes
that little gnawing feeling you get that
little nine where you feel like I feel
like I need to eat something he said
that is when you are going into your fat
stores and you can either feed that
feeling give it food or you can say oh
this is when my body is going into my
fat stores and it's gonna now eat the
stored fat that's what that feeling is
and so what happens with most of us we
try to feed that feeling and then you
wake up and you're you you're back
you're back so what you're what you
really want to look for is that little
that it took ten years you telling me
that we're walking I go you mean that's
it that's it that little thing that says
I want to eat something not I'm starving
but I wish and most of us what you do is
you go to the cabinet you open the
cabinets and you start grazing you gotta
go down this is what I've done before
you say is it rice krispy no is
Oh maybe some chocolate no let me try I
have a pork chop but that's what you
want you want to feel like when you go
to bed at night you want to feel like I
wish I could eat a little something and
that's the moment when your body's going
we're gonna go into you but out of the
time what is it about what you do that
triggers the adaptation response and
what adaptation response does it trigger
the power to adapt to this stressor in
general we lost this connection is
because we wear clothes all the time and
we live in a comfort zone behavior we
think we can control nature but by being
non stimulative in our behavior we lost
the connection in the depth of our
physiology cause we are able to adapt
about to anything we are built to be
able to adapt without stress into any
stressful situation again a solution the
body knows but because we got into this
comfort zone behavior hundreds of years
our genetics have changed our physiology
has changed everything has changed and
we lost actually the full power of the
mind and I'm here to bring it back how
do we bring it back I did many studies
already because I don't like speculation
I go through study this scrutiny and let
any scientist prove me wrong because I
like to go through the truth because I
think there is more than meets the eye I
did many studies and yes I could resist
the bacteria as thought of not being
able by humans we changed medical
history by showing a group of people
compared to sixteen thousand one hundred
and thirty-four people becoming sick
after injection of a endotoxemia and
then suddenly twelve hundred
and school within a quarter of our
complete control over the innate immune
system and is specific by the way the
adaptive immune system and how did I
learn to do that and to pass it on
because it's already there in us it only
needs to awaken the finally adaptive
immune system the adaptive immune system
is willfully regulating and controlling
your t-cells and b-cells and they are
located in the bone marrow we are able
to wilfully influence the bone marrow
and to release the T and beta B cells
which are very specific in the targeting
on the bacteria and the virus and
apoptosis cell death they created
instead of fever and uncontrolled
shivering and and headaches and being
sick flus fever and all that is the
second layer we got into the third layer
into the depth of the immune system into
the deepest so willfully being able to
get into the bone marrow and release the
T and B cells in case of inflammation is
what we and inflammation I tell you is
the course of any disease did you just
say that you can willfully control
apoptosis yes anybody can okay for that
we have the breathing exercises and it
has been shown in the comparative study
all the guys who did their breathing
exercises the end of talk see normally
creates inflammation and thus
uncontrolled shivering all over agony
headaches and fever and their people
really get sick after injected being
injected with the bacteria E coli and
that's normal but it was not normal to
be able to inoculate that reaction how
did we do that by breathing exercises
that are like controlled hypoxia where
through the brain stem the fight and
flight suddenly activates the adrenaline
and resets the body and resetting the
body is going past our comfort zone
conditioning going back in our
primordial state the way nature meant it
to be and that is being able effectively
to battle this is very simple very
effective very accessible for any human
in the world and that we go a step
further a Stepford is the last study
wherein I was exposed to cold water and
just by a thought I was able to make the
skin temperature not going down well I
was exposed to cold water on my skin ice
water
your skin temperature dun dun yes and
normally it goes down that is what
everybody thinks isn't it and yes 74
people before me they did it and they
saw all the same graphics it goes down
after exposure to cold water and when
warm water comes up then it goes up
again and goes down called walk cold
walk cold walk and then I did it same I
didn't do anything
why because I'm in command of my breath
and with that I become in command of my
alchemy and I'm able than to scent and
to manipulate any part of my body they
looked inside the brain and whereas
normally a stress comes to work on the
body and that could be cold could be
heat but could also be emotion
depression bipolar anxiety fear PTSD
trauma it's all stress in the brain and
it gets inflamed and we don't know how
to break the loop now they looked inside
of my brain while this stressor was gone
on and I stayed out of de-stresser when
the call came in I just stayed over
there and a warmth cold wolf I stay in
control and then they looked inside the
brain and whereas normally the activity
of the stress is highlighting the
prefrontal cortex the conscious brain
because it's cold
oh I feel bad because I'm divorced now
and this and that and my business is
gone and whatever you know stress real
stress and that the insula which is
normally active very activated when you
go into deep meditation then the insula
gets becoming more rat and then this is
blue because deactivates the normal
daily consciousness and the insula the
deep meditation is oh and blood flow
goes in the deeper parts of the brain
suddenly becomes all active and its
pleasant it's nice before ik if you go
into the eyes you're really not thinking
about your mortgage or your wife or this
or that you are not going to picnic you
feel the focus will be on your feeling
how to get this feeling into adaptation
and to overcome whatever is coming and
it goes directly and I tell you the the
cold has been my teacher I just follow
the teacher the feeling learned to let
go
intuitively I felt I want to do this I
did yoga did come food it or all kinds
of things and and a great part the cold
is really merciless but righteous and I
was ready to go in I felt intuitively I
want to go in because it has got
something I don't know what it is and
yes I went in and I felt it the
connection was there beyond any word and
that's what I was looking for this
tapping into deeper part of the brain
feeling pure energy feeling our innate
capacity the power we have to deal with
that I was looking for that and since
then I went on and on and on oh no I did
all these records and many more
challenges I did crazy stuff really
sitting all the night in your shorts
outside in freezing temperatures and
feel great that is something that is
power and I've been venturing and
discovering more and more
and finally I began to realize but it's
all in the mind
oh yes so learning to let go in the
right way following your breath the
breath is able to prime the body and
then your mind the neurology of the mind
if I'm able to make my skin temperature
not going down well being exposed to ice
cold water skin temperature that's power
and that power is the same power we can
learn to embrace and awaken in which we
are able to tackle any stressor in the
world any stressor
emotionally and physically and mentally
whatever here you come up we are built
to be able to oppose that to get through
and to learn and not to be afraid
because we have the power of the mind it
seems like there's two things to your
method number one is the breath so what
I want to know is when you're breathing
in the way that you're breathing which
there's a lot of great video on there
that will link to in the show notes so
when you're breathing like that why do
you think that allows you to begin to
reconnect to something that everyone
will call the autonomic system meaning
that you don't have conscious control
over how does that link it yes a very
simple these breathing techniques I've
learned to do in extreme cold so they
are stream ly effective very soon I was
able to stay and prolong my time in ice
water feeling great but is the breath
just about oxygenating the tissues
oxygenating not only to go past in this
case to go past the lymphatic knots
which normally inhibits the oxygen to go
deeper now we found a way to go past
these knots into the lymphatic system
and with that you come into the depth of
your body and making you able to
alkalize you blood within a couple of
minutes and with that a when the blood
is the right pH degree then suddenly the
neural
of the mind which is like electricity is
able to run through on a subtle basis
actually we are mammals we are about you
know we are built after millions of
years as mammals
if you geology's inside the wiring and
everything is inside and three times the
world's length is vascular systems
inside of us killer number one in our
society is cardiovascular related it's
big time and that is because we wear
clothes we are never being a stammer
stimulated through cold warm and
pressure it's no longer there so there
is a mediocre state of our vascular
conditioning and that avoid that we take
cold showers then there's some shock to
the system that does hormesis or we do
it consciously and with that we connect
even with the brain with the vascular
system all over and it's amazing how
simple it can be how simple we can take
the tackle this serial killer their
cardiovascular related diseases we can
tackle it in a cold shower a day keeps
the doctor away I want to go back to
when you're 17 yes the ice water starts
calling to you and also part of what
makes us fascinating is you have an
identical twin yes
so one it's fascinating that you guys
took very divergent paths so if I
understand right you've begun to teach
him your method yes but when you're
there at the water and it's calling to
you what what is that like it's 17 I
know you've been searching searching for
like I need this this whatever this is I
need it all to make sense I need to
connect to a God or something to fill me
up to let me connect to something bigger
than myself so yes you have that calling
I don't know what but it is there and it
is inside of me and it's more than meets
the eye and all that and it made me at a
age of 12 study psychology and going
into Hinduism Buddhism and all kinds of
esoteric disciplines and when I was 17
ugh I just had this feeling
and my twin brother who's identical is
not able to do only after my training to
come up with the result because it's not
genetical it is trained and so this one
is able to be trained by any body to
have the fact that you're an identical
twin it's like you're the perfect
subject I mean it's literally crazy you
have an identical twin to be like the
the perfect control subject yes yes
absolutely it's like hundred percent
genetical score match and he is not able
to do it and I'm not and I'm able to do
it so they did certain kinds of
experiments and they saw this in
scientific environment that I was able
to do things and he could not and the
later when I trained him he was able to
do about the same Jesus that's that's
extraordinary
we all are able to battle inflammation
to have a control top down in our body
much more than we thought possible at
least to be able to guarantee happiness
strength and health which is all related
to a hormones and the control over the
immune system and nervous system gets
your physical condition you just need
Leslie your metabolic rate is higher you
have a lot more energy a lot more
stamina
a lot more Patchi get super fit and
you're just going to need Leslie number
two every single week get a massage
getting a massage is not a waste of time
it's not a cost it's an investment why
because it will increase your
circulation it'll help you get by on a
lot less sleep but something that arrow
repeat performers should do every seven
days just to allow yourself to play
interrupts the best number through your
diet eat less food you'll have more
energy don't eat after eight o'clock and
eat every four hours a little bit of
protein a little bit of carbs but the
real key is eat less food manage your
diet you will need lastly the most
common question I've been asked by the
media of my entire life that always
makes me wear outfits don't you have bad
days don't jet days when you're like
fresh day and anxiety pissed off and you
watch TV and you eat Cheetos and watch
pornography and I said why do some of
those things and of course I do but what
I it's like an athlete I built muscle
over the years so that it's not that I
don't have feelings and I'd get her to
sign up I feel all those things but
they're not the dominant force in my
life
it's a muscle the mind is a muscle
emotion is a muscle I mean I think the
most powerful muscles are the invisible
force muscles it's your spiritual
emotional muscles like courage on youth
doesn't grow streaks so I put my ass on
the line regularly so that it grows and
when it keeps growing then pretty soon
those stuff that used to make me crazy
it doesn't touch me it's not that I'm so
great just I'm well trained I ran this
mine I get up every morning my life you
talk about rebounder more crazy ideas
everywhere in your life if I'm near if
I'm near any of my homes in some places
I have I have cryotherapy but my homes I
have these Co plungers and they're 56°
and the first thing I do is jump in that
cold punch there's not a morning where I
want to jump in that I can't remember
one good job a nothing but I don't
negotiate with myself I do it for two
reasons one there's a physical health
component moves your lymph system and
the blood rushes through your whole body
but the main reason I do it even more
than that is when I go up there I don't
you know people negotiate laughs I'm
able to tomorrow I'm gonna do this or
I'll let me wait two more minutes time
ready first manage with me for decades I
go I say do I'm not here to discuss this
with my mind
there's mind and then there's soul and
spirit and soul spirit my soul knows it
when I say jump you jump I'm not here to
have a discussion with you thirty and a
half I'm gonna strand and fly I'm just
laying there not feeling tired not
feeling lethargic
a thing no heart burned I think I'm
getting a heart attack nothing I'm just
laying there and I'm saying you know if
I treated my health the way I treated
businesses I'd win and so I just started
actually I remember what happened cuz I
was like that's not doesn't feel right I
was thinking about my 40th birthday and
I was thinking you know at 30 I changed
my life I went from the executor to I
need to go for it if I don't do from 30
to 40 it's not gonna happen so let me go
for it in that decade and I was like
what am I to do at 40 weirdly I don't
feel the same pressure I did at 30 I
think I'm at a better career path like I
don't feel the angst to like it didn't
feel right to triple down on work and so
I said health health is nowhere close to
where it should be
I'm not I'm I'm the way I make fun of
people in business you're not doing
anything right that's gonna help you
long term I'm not doing anything right
with health when I turned 40 I'm gonna
get serious so then a week later I'm
gonna flight again flights made me think
and I'm like am I waiting 244 I can do a
lot of bad in this next 18 months 39 in
November it is around May and in
November I'm gonna go for it and
literally the next morning I'm like why
among the first five ingredients you
shouldn't find sugar okay now sugar
supposed to beat and of course but it
should come together with either fat or
some element like fiber as you were
finding fruit so you can ignite you can
absorb it a bit more slowly but number
one so sugar is one of the first five
elements in whatever it is you're buying
it's a no no no no you want to avoid it
okay now even worse than sugar even
worse than sugar is this look appetizing
that is that is this is high fructose
corn syrup oh that's what it is now it's
at its very sweet yeah but it's not very
good for you it's not good for you
because it blocks the ability of a
chemical called leptin which is the way
your fat tells your brain
exactly okay so you know what this is
the thing that's blocking it and so you
just keep eating and eating until you
literally stops right yeah it's not so
much even the hundred and fifty calories
in the soda pop it's the fact that at
that same meal you will normally consume
an extra hundred calories of food and
you would have because of this because
of this
high-fructose corn syrup okay got that
these are both carbohydrates yes
the third carbohydrate is this yes this
is flour but it's enriched white flour
enriched so why would they enriched
flour
the reason they enriched it is because
they already stripped out anything that
was worth adorned in it and they add a
little bit back so it doesn't look so
bad yes it should be
whole-grain okay wait till has those
kernels it has this B vitamins all the
things you want to be in there whole
grains hip it's in it okay so these
three are carbohydrates yes let's move
on down to the fun stuff okay now big
confusion about fats yeah big this is
animal fat yes animal fat is saturated
saturated fat is from four-legged
animals that good if it's coming from a
four-legged animal its saturated so that
means these things can be solid at room
temperature
okay large thing card bingo saturated
think large good oils good oils our oil
our liquids at room temperature
repeating so I'm putting it in my brain
okay now the thing about good oils is
that they're not very stable if you put
a good oil into a cracker and try to
store it on a shelf it goes bad uh-huh
because good oils aren't very stable so
in order to deal with that problem
we took the good healthy vegetable oils
and we hydrogenated them we added
hydrogen's to them okay tell me that
again we took good healthy oils okay and
in order to make them solid yeah and
make them so they wouldn't go bad in a
year on a shelf somewhere aha we added
hydrogen's to them hydrogen rice
hydrogen okay makes those flimsy things
become rigid and that's what I make it
stay on the shelf for a year well it
makes it solid at room temperature and
solid on a shelf for a year okay and
that's this this should be liquid it's
obviously not oh this is very good for
your skin and you can actually use this
kind of material for furniture polish
lots of fun things yeah but don't put it
in you I can use it on my feet
good I'm thinking this is a great
moisturizer my heel this is nice yeah
okay and this is what what is this lard
no this this is actually a hydrogenated
oil okay it's it's a material that is
created so that you can keep that stored
material on Michelle for long time
here's the big deal when you have
healthy oils yeah and you cook with them
mm-hmm you oxidize them you damage them
so the key thing to know about the
healthy oils and what are the healthy
oil olive oil sesame seed oil they're
all the ones that are liquid when
they're Clack seed oil when they're cold
right some are better than others but
generally the ones I just listed you
know a canola oil flaxseed oil olive oil
these are all very healthy oils but
because they're healthy they're very
delicate yes so you have to store them
in a refrigerator or at least cover them
so they stay dark otherwise they will
turn they will oxidize they will go bad
on you oh really so this stuff is great
because doesn't go bad but it's very bad
for you okay so the healthy oils if you
learn how to use them take you a long
way put some on my heels and this is in
a lot of things this is the hydrogenated
oil correct yes this is hydrogenated to
make it solid okay and then by the word
that you will see in the package is a
trans fat because these hydrogen's bring
these molecules together and we call
them trans fats so I don't want the
thing to say hydrogenated and I don't
want it to say trans fat and I don't
want it to say saturated exactly you
just hit the nail on the head I was
teaching in a medical school yeah and I
was teaching the concept about jeans and
everyone of course heard about jeans and
they believe that jeans control their
lives you know so running in my family
is on diabetes Alzheimer's cancer
whatever it is and they say oh my
goodness I'm a recipient of such genes
and this is going to be my life and this
is a belief of victimization of
victimization of heredity it's running
in my reddit the--and i going to get
these jeans and i can't control it
there's a new biology that switches this
whole thing around because it reveals
that genes don't control our lives
it's our perceptions and our response to
the environment to see
vironment that influence the genes well
the relevance about that is since we can
change our perception so we can change
our environment then we're not victims
we're actually masters but we have to
know that we have to really come from an
understanding that we are creating our
lives because if your belief is you're a
victim its belief is translated into
biology you become a victim if that's
what you believe yes sir
so you kind of prove scientifically and
biologically that the proof of that that
that we in fact are in control of our
genes that our genes aren't controlling
allies can you give us a brief sort of
bird's-eye view of how you prove that
yep there's a wonderful simple
experiment about 47 years ago I was
cloning stem cells now back 47 years ago
there's only a handful of us in the
whole world even knew what a stem cell
is it's a stem cells an embryonic cell
in your body and the reason why we have
all these embryonic cells because cells
have a life and they die and if we can't
replace the cells then it won't be very
long before all our cells die and then
we're gone so in stem cell is a multi
potential embryonic cell here's what
works simple I get one stem cell put it
in a dish by itself and it divides every
10 hours so first one and then two for
age 16 and the cells keep going after a
week I've got 50,000 cells in the petri
dish but here's the most important point
they all came from one parent so they're
50,000 genetically identical cells okay
now here's the experiment here I take
that community and I break them up into
three different petri dishes and I
change the environment a little bit in
each dish now cells are like fish they
live in a fluid so I create like an
aquarium with all the things they need
to live in it that's called the
environment and I change the composition
of the environment a little bit in each
dish okay what happens is in dish one I
get muscle cells in dish 2 I end up with
a different environment get bone cells
in dish 3 yet a different environment I
end up with fat cells well the whole
point was this what controls the fate of
the cells and you say well genetics I go
no no they were all genetically the same
is so the fate of the cell wasn't
determined by the genetics it was
determined by the environment ok and so
the information in the environment is
really what's involved with selecting
our genes so people say well ok that's
really nice you got cells in a plastic
dish what the heck does that have to do
with me
here's the fun part you look in the
mirror ty you look you see this handsome
guy looking back you say that's ty
that's me and I'm a single human being a
single organism I go a slight
misperception for this reason you are
not a single entity you are made out of
50 trillion cells the cells are the
living entity you by actual biological
definition your community so your
community of 50 trillion cells and so
the fun part is you're a skin covered
petri dish with 50 trillion cells inside
and you have an environment a culture
medium and it's called blood and the
chemical composition of the blood
determines the fate of the cells that's
what happened in my plastic dish so to a
cell does it make a difference if it's
in the plastic dish of the skin dish no
it's still going to read the environment
so I say oh then the blood is the
culture medium and the composition of
the blood controls the genetics and then
I go yeah now here's the cool part say
but as I showed in the petri dish if I
change the composition of the of the
culture medium I change the fate of the
cells so I say well who or what controls
the chemical composition of my blood so
we go up to the next all I say the brain
is the chemist the brain is what
releases the chemistry in the blood and
then you go one more step you said but
what chemicals should the brain release
into the blood I go next level up the
mind what do you perceive what do you
see what are you looking for so I say
for a given person I say here we are a
stand here I open up my eyes and I see
someone I love well my mind perceives
love and translates that through the
brain into chemistry such as dopamine
the pleasure chemical oxytocin a bonding
chemical vasopressin attractiveness
growth hormone which enhances the growth
of cells so when a person sees love
experiences love the brain releases a
cocktail of these wonderful chemicals
and and think about it when people are
in love they glow yeah they're healthy
they're you have so much energy I said
where'd they get that from the culture
medium okay but I say the same person
opens your eyes instead of seeing
someone they love they see someone
that's something that scares them I say
do you release these same chemicals in
love and I go No
when I perceive the world is threatening
where I living in fear I released stress
hormones and I release a hormone to
control my immune system inflammatory
agents these things that get me ready
for flight or flight and I go well
here's interesting part as I said the
fate of the cells is based on the
chemistry if I take the chemicals
released by the brain and love and put
it into a plastic dish with cells yeah
the cells grow beautifully I say okay
wait what about the chemicals that come
out of a brain of someone in fear I take
those chemicals put that in the culture
dish the cells stop growing and and
again into protection protections close
yourself down so the idea is this when
you're in growth you're open to the
world and you say come out and bring it
on
yeah but one fear or something comes in
there you close it down and the
chemistry of the fear is what shuts down
the cells fear kills basically what it's
all about
so basically says this we always talk
about my body and those strict
fundamental scientists go and Barney
would run and I go it's not a mystery
it's simple the mind is an
interpretation of the world it causes
the brain to release chemistry that
matches the interpretation to coordinate
50 trillion cells to live in that world
it's your emotions it's your perception
since your beliefs these are the sources
of the chemicals that end up controlling
the genes as this is a new science it's
called epigenetics because epigenetics
is a revolution of all of our
understanding of science for a very
simple reason when I was a professor in
a medical school we were teaching the
concept of genetics and genetics most
everybody knows yes we have genes and
the genes control our traits and that we
get the genes from our parents and and
so therefore the traits that are running
in our family are passed down to us and
sometimes it's a good thing and
sometimes the families is running your
family saying oh geez everybody my
family got cancer it's like am I gonna
be next well I got the genes yeah so
that's our belief system that we've been
teaching at genes control us that makes
us victims as I said because we didn't
pick the genes as far as we know we
can't change the genes so whatever they
are they make us and so people walk
around going oh my life is you know not
so good I got these genes epi means
above
so when I say epigenetic control I'm
literally saying control above the genes
it's the environment that controls it
well that includes not just the real
environment but our perception of the
environment because you could live in
the healthiest of environments but if
you perceive it to be a threatening
world then it's your cells receive the
perception they don't read the direct
world genetic control your victim
because of genes control you epigenetics
is a revolution because it says look if
the environment or my perception
controls genes I'm the one that can
change my perception I'm the one that
can change my environment so all of a
sudden I'm not locked in I am free to
change the way I live in the world which
in turn comes back and changes the
genetic readout and this is really
what's so profoundly important for
example a lot of people talk about the
placebo effect yes and they say well
what's the placebo effect well this pill
is going to cure you it's the greatest
new science in the world and I believe
that and I take the pill and I get
better and then they tell me it was just
a sugar pill so then the truth is
well what healed me well it wasn't the
sugar pill it was the belief in the pill
so everyone says well yeah placebo
effect that's it you have this wonderful
thought you get better and I say yeah
but here's the problem we've only talked
about the placebo effect there's another
thing called the nocebo effect the
nocebo effect is what is the consequence
of a negative thought and it turns out
it's equally powerful and controlling
your biology and your genetics as is a
powerful as a placebo positive thought
yeah so we talked about oh yea placebo
good thoughts create good health and
good life and then I say yeah and a bad
thought a negative thought a nocebo
effect can actually kill you it can
cause the disease if you believe you're
gonna get this cancer because everyone
says you're gonna get this cancer and
then your perception is sending cancer
thoughts into your body the chemistry
that comes from the thoughts to the
brain to the body is a chemistry that
doesn't support health but it'll
actually lead to your own death so all
of a sudden it's the power of your
perceptions positive or negative that
overrides your genetics well this is
most amazing because all those sudden
you look around
so but look at all those wonderful happy
people and look they're not only just
happy they're also healthy yes and the
fact is yes they're sending in a
chemistry that the cells will really
thrive with now I've got a special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the best live
30 questions of the day it's not enough
to just watch a video like this you have
to do something and take action in your
life so pull out your worksheets and
answer these questions and if you don't
have the worksheets yet you can get them
for free by signing up for the series in
the description below here we go
question number one what are the
lifestyle changes that you need to make
to improve your health number two when
is your eating cutoff time going to be
and number three what do you want to
train your mind to do better and if
you're doing the best life 30 challenge
with me give me a hashtag best live 30
down the comments as well so I can
celebrate you growing up as you get into
your 30s you know the weight starts
adding up especially for entrepreneurs
living a busy lifestyle and I quickly
found myself to being almost 200 pounds
and so I decided I got to get my act
together I got to lose some weight some
of you guys have been commenting and
notice saying thank you for the love and
so in today's video I'm gonna share with
you the seven ways that I use to lose 19
and a half pounds in one month
[Music]
so way number one is I would fast until
noon and fasten for me would be liquids
only and really does just water lots of
water here and coffee now this probably
wasn't the healthiest part I would have
two of these that would last me from
whenever I woke up usually around seven
ish until twelve o'clock one o'clock and
this is an extra-large two milk one
sugar from Tim Hortons so having two
extra-large coffees
probably wasn't the healthiest choice in
the morning but I found that one the
caffeine really helped curb the appetite
and I found if I delayed my eating until
the afternoon then I could consume the
calories that I needed in the afternoon
and not get started too early I found
when I started eating too early then
that I just kept eating all day long and
I found it difficult to kind of stay on
the diet its 11:55
decisions what have I got a hoarder eat
and so fast into noon only water and
coffee and then we eat my first meal at
noon at the earliest sometimes one or
even 1:30 wait number two is 30 minutes
of cardio every day what I found the
easiest thing to do was actually just at
night at 9 o'clock I would set a routine
that my wife and I would usually watch
something on TV some show we'd watch
arrow or billions or what else we watch
arrow billions from Gotham blind spot we
mix between the shows we sit down at 9 9
o'clock and I would run on the spot
at 9 o'clock so it'd just be like while
we're watching the show I'd be like this
I'd be running running running for half
an hour after that I do some stretching
and usually those shows when no
commercials go about 40 ish minutes 42
minutes so it's the perfect time so I
knew 9 o'clock watch the show half an
hour running 10 to 12 minutes of
stretching afterwards it was the perfect
setting and then have a shower and get
ready for bed I've seen suggesting it
just recently where I do a morning run
instead I usually run to the local Whole
Foods that's about 15 minutes away then
pick up a kombucha some salad bananas
maybe and come back but for most of that
weight loss journey it was a nine
o'clock 30-minute run and I did that
every single day of the week
[Music]
we number three is I use a Seinfeld
technique and the Seinfeld technique is
to print a calendar for the year so
here's mine
my calendar for the year and basically
every single day you want to mark it off
with an X on the calendar when you've
done that thing and so for me the two
things I was tracking was running 30
minutes a day and fast until noon if I
did that I would get an X and so the
goal is to not break the chain and so
every single day I would get my X and
you can see here I started it this just
before my May 21st date so May 21st is
what here somewhere and up until June
21st which is today that's not quite
noon filming this yet so I can't mark it
off but that really helped just kind of
stay on track and you'd like to see the
progress and when you see those X's
coming on you don't want to break the
chain and so you want to keep going
every day wait number 4 was a used
Saturday as a cheat day and that was
when I could eat whatever I wanted you
know there was no calorie restriction
that just ate ate ate ate ate ate ate
but I still had to keep my chain so I
still was running for 30 minutes in the
day and I was still fasting until noon
this was one of the hardest things
because I get this delicious doughnut
from Tim Hortons or this breakfast that
ends at noon and so I really wanted to
eat dad so he buy it a couple minutes
early I'd be sitting there looking at my
doughnut like I got five minutes left
before I can eat this thing
and then once noon came but show it in
so Saturday is my cheat day
but I still am on my fast until noon
it's 15 minutes till noon and I'm
excited to dig into my Boston cream
doughnut this is gonna be a brutal 15
minutes I love it so that really helped
that helps it helps on a psychological
level to have one day when you can eat
whatever you want and I think there is
also a lot of research that backs up
having a cheat day to kind of spike your
levels and then come back down can
actually facilitate more weight loss as
well and so I found that really helpful
but I kept to my fasting until noon and
running 30 minutes a day guys when you
persevere and it's hard and you make it
through and you win the victory is just
so much sweeter
[Music]
we number five was no packaged foods and
so I made a decision apart from the
coffee that would have in the morning I
wouldn't need anything from a package so
nothing with a wrapper nothing
store-bought that was not just processed
but even healthy stuff I wouldn't eat
from a wrapper so we need protein bars
before and just other things some
packaged and decided nope not gonna do
it anymore and most of my diet consists
of fish we don't really eat a lot of
meat except on Saturdays just fish and
vegetables fish vegetables nuts
mostly assortment of whitefish Cod
different filets haddock walleye bunch
of stuff Nina's been fantastic in
helping kind of prepare all the foods
and it's great having a partner on this
journey so she's eaten basically the
same stuff I am and then broccoli and
cabbage and green beans and sugar snap
peas and it's basically pretty easy to
get filled up because you're only really
in two big meals a day I would start
usually at noon eating a banana
- bananas probably two bananas sometimes
three bananas in a day and then into my
lunch and then into my dinner and that
would be it
I would snack on nuts and everything
basically not from a package trying to
trying to say healthy strata stay clean
and it's really helped with the weight
loss way number six is used My Fitness
Pal My Fitness Pal is an app that allows
you to track your calories and I'll load
it up here to show you guys so what you
do is put in the foods can you see can
you see can you see anyway
what you can do is you they have goals
this is a free app that's put out by
Under Armor I think it's under armour
you can put in your goals of how high
you are how like how how high you are
you pick how tall you are what your goal
is for weight and how quickly you want
to achieve it and they'll give you a
calorie target and then you can enter in
your food and it gives you a sense of
what every single meal looks like and so
if you're eating an avocado you might
think that's really healthy but has a
lot of calories and so just being able
to bounce it out if you are educated to
know what is in your food there are days
that I will go to
Tim Hortons and get a crispy chicken
sandwich which is fried chicken and
bread and you know fairly high calories
like 540 calories something like that
but it fits it fits within my day and so
just educating yourself on how many
calories are in each meal is great it
has a barcode scanners so if you are
eating out then you can easily find most
of the foods that the major chains if
you are even eating from a package you
can barcode scan it and it'll tell you
the nutritional breakdown on it and
it'll tell you how much you should be
eating in terms of protein fat and
carbohydrates and then you can see am i
matching up I think the biggest thing
for me was just recognizing the
difference in the foods and educating
myself so I could eat more appropriately
and match my intake to where I should be
and so why we do a lot of fish is
because it's insanely high protein so
you get your protein targets easily and
not a lot of calories and so if you're
eating that it's a lot easier to fill up
your day with other stuff that you want
to eat because you're hitting your
targets at a really low calorie level so
I would highly recommend check you know
eye Fitness Pal free to use and there's
a premium program that you can upgrade
to I don't use it but you can and it'll
help you on your journey and way number
seven this is the most recent thing that
I'm doing I'm trying to substitute out
coffee for kombucha and so kombucha is
supposed to be super healthy full of
probiotics gots a got a whole bunch of
stuff floating around in it and I do my
morning run to Whole Foods pick up a
kombucha I am now between one kombucha
and no coffees two to one coffee a day
and I'm slowly starting to substitute at
the coffee I come for kombucha during
the week the coffee is the only thing
really in my diet
apart from Saturday that that is junky
that is not healthy that is from a box
that is packaged and so I want to slowly
reduce that and replace it with the
kombucha and then on weekend Saturday
Saturday only eat whatever I want and so
those are the seven things that's really
helped me on my weight loss journey
again at the beginning I never thought I
had to worry about it growing up was
always super skinny and always healthy
and at some point
catches up with you and you got to
decide to invest in yourself and and be
healthy if you want to join the best
life 30 challenge and get the free
worksheets click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to optimize your diet check out the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you there